en este problema nos dicen que el rayo o
l es perpendicular al rayo o n es decir
este ángulo de acá es de 90 grados
también nos dicen que la medida del
ángulo lm es decir este de acá es de 2 x
46 2 x + 46 y finalmente nos dicen que
la medida del ángulo m n es igual a 3 x
63 x menos 6 y con esta información
debemos determinar la medida del ángulo
m en este este de acá y para hacer eso
bastará encontrar cuánto vale x ya que
una vez que tengamos eso basta
multiplicar por 3 y restar 6 para
encontrar esta medida sale bueno y para
encontrar ese valor de x lo que vamos a
hacer es aprovechar que estos dos
ángulos son complementarios
es decir suman 90 grados porque forman
el ángulo entre los rayos o l y/o n que
sabemos que son perpendiculares entonces
deja de apuntar esto por acá tenemos que
2x 46
2 x 46 3 x 6
+ 3x menos 6 es igual a 90 a 90 por
suponer que todo está en grado sale es
igual a 90 grados y con esta ecuación
ahora podemos despejar x juntando 2x con
3x nos queda 5x juntando 46 menos 6 46
menos 6 nos queda más 40 y eso de ahí es
igual a 90 90 podemos restar 40 de ambos
lados restamos 40 que restamos 40 acá
aquí se cancelan de modo que nos queda
que 5x es igual a 50 a 50 y finalmente
dividiendo entre 5 nos queda que x aquí
se cancela nos queda que x es igual a 10
pero nosotros no queríamos el valor de x
sino el valor de la medida del ángulo
m/n que es 3x menos 6
bueno pues va a estar sustituir este
valor a cada verdad tenemos que 3x
- 6 es igual a 3 por 10 3 por 10 6 menos
6 y 3 por 10 es 30 menos 6 es igual a 24
24 entonces la medida del ángulo m n es
igual a 24 grados